it's happening it's happening we are
that close Stargate and RoboCop
announcements very very soon welcome to
sidre your Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel
slightly excited Movie
[Music]
Channel right so I've got a little bit
of a story to tell you and if you're not
a patreon not going to know any of this
but Sunday very late Sunday we got an
email from one of our very good sources
this is one of the sources that has been
really really reliable it was actually
the first person that ever come to us
that back then they used to work at MGM
and now they work for one of the big
talent agencies in basically Hollywood
one of the big two he basically told me
you need to get in touch with this other
person that works very closely with a
very large PR firm that does some
consultancy work for Amazon and you need
to get in touch with them now I'm being
told and the rumor is that Stargate is
going to be announced this week that MGM
were going to announce three big
projects and he said potentially within
the next week now this was Sunday night
he then come back to us and said there's
a lot of words rumors and SE swirling
round and actually what he then told me
the next day was that one of the agents
that work for this firm was in the
building with his full team and he says
that never happens they never have the
full team in the building at the same
time and they actually dragged somebody
in from legal into several meetings
during that day now this agent he says
basically manages directors that's his
thing he he manages a lot of directors
and producers so he is the agent for
this a director he said the only reason
to have them all in and then to drag
legal in is if they are signing a
contract on something and the Rumor was
it's Amazon he said to me Amazon are
clicking their fingers that's the
whisper that's going around the office
now he says there there's loads of
directors involved here so there's no
way of knowing necessarily who they're
talking to but if they're talking to
somebody and getting legal involved it's
not an unfair assumption to say there is
going to be a contract involved what did
we say are the three main things we need
for a Stargate
announcement a script we think we've
already got one a director it looks like
he might be about or she might be about
to sign a contract and then a leading
star with the actor strike they're not
going to get the leading man or woman
the star but will they maybe trigger an
announcement as long as they've got at
least two of those things very possibly
Amazon have done that before but why do
I think it's going to be announced very
soon other than this rumor now I don't
think the person I actually speak to the
email me Sunday's correct about this
happening within a week I think that is
potentially um a little bit of Chinese
Whispers because then I actually did
speak to a person that does work in and
around the pr marketing internally at
MGM they've actually told me that
marketing and PR has been ordered to
review all of the plans they had for the
announcements of MGM projects in the
next 12 months
and basically to redo any that need
doing so update the plans they had that
they were going to announce this summer
and get back to bosses by the end of the
week now I think that rumor because this
actually happened um at the end of last
week apparently I think that has gone
around the industry and that's where
this one week thing is coming in but to
just to clarify internally MGM marketing
and PR are looking at all of their plans
they had for projects they were going to
announce the Su are just gone that they
didn't because of the strikes they are
to basically review them and propose new
ones if any of those plans are now out
of date or they just have new ideas on
how to do it basically as well they're
going to have to change at very least
the plan for Stargate because we know
the plan was to announce it at San Diego
ComicCon so they are going to have to
propose a different way to announce
Stargate now
I actually then did speak to the pr firm
that and the lady that works at the pr
firm the very large PR firm that does
consultancy work for Amazon and they
have been able to confirm to me that
their suggestion when Consulting for
Amazon was that MGM and Amazon should go
about announcing projects as quickly as
possible the argument that they've
basically come back with is that
actually Amazon as a studio has kept
pretty much out of the strikes they've
not been front and center they've not
actually been tarnished with the brush
of negativity that a lot of the other
Studios have that the public perception
is that actually Disney and other big
studios like Warner Brothers are to
blame for a lot of these problems and
Studios like Amazon have really got away
with it got free so their suggestion is
for Amazon to announce anything that
they've got ready to go quickly take
advantage of a little bit of public
opinion in their face for once and
actually start getting people excited
about what might be coming next summer
and the summer after it does look like
that Amazon are following this
suggestion they have ordered their
marketing people internally to start
getting these plans ready they want
reports by the end of the week so yes it
looks like we might be getting an
announcement for Stargate Robocop and
many other projects very very quickly
I'm starting to think I don't think
they're going to make Amazon day Amazon
day is like the 10th and 11th we did
wonder whether they might try and
announce it by then unless it's just a a
statement you know on their website sort
thing I think that's probably
unlikely but if they do decide I'm
thinking before Christmas is very very
possible but the main thing is it's
happening it's happening now it is
happening right now in the offices at
MGM we can get excited about it finally
we're going to get the announcement we
want
and also remember that actually the
source that I speak to MGM remember that
they said to me just over a week ago
that there's no decision been made on
whether the movie Stargate was going to
be theatrical release or a straight to
streaming release but it would be a
movie The Source actually told me that
the decision was going to be made within
two weeks so that would be the week
coming so they're getting their
marketing ready and then they're going
to be making the final decision on where
the movie is going to go which I think
will then affect the budget I think the
next week coming is going to be very
very important for these projects so
we're very excited we're very happy here
on this channel we're really really
happy that once again we can get this to
you first and exclusively please share
the video with all of your Stargate
friends we want everyone to know that
this is coming this is happening we want
people to start getting excited about it
but also I want you to get into the
comments and tell me what you think do
you think this all makes sense do you
think that really the studio is would be
mad not to and how excited are you how
many Chevrons are locked for you I'm at
like 6.3 qus 6.9 I'm at 6.9 6.9 Chevrons
locked I can't say fairer than that get
into the comments though and tell me
exactly what you think and if you are
new to the channel don't forget to click
all those buttons like subscribe share
the video wherever the hell you want and
also go to patreon.com for/ cirre where
I've actually been dropping little Quick
videos on this all week so that all of
the patreon members knew as this
information came in if you want to know
when stuff comes in instantly the same
as them then please go and check out the
website as always please stay safe 6.9
chevron's locked I'll see you next
[Music]
time